Musik
Musik Musik Musik Musik Denn Samstag trinke ich Bier aus der Dose und freu mich auf die pur-mutzige Dose. Hey Leute, herzlich willkommen! Oh Gott, Flo, ihr hatt's abgeschnitten. Schön, dass ihr ihn bitte. Flo, ihr hatt's abgeschnitten. Ich hab's nicht abgeschnitten, das war so gewollt, und zwar von Tobias, Max, Hans und Svenja, die sich hier zu viert zusammengetan haben zu Les Fez oder einem anderen Bandnamen, den ich nicht weiß. Oder hoffentlich jedem anderen Bandnamen. Ich drücke Ihnen das jetzt so auf, so können Sie auf jeden Fall auftreten. Vielen, vielen Dank. Ich habe mich wirklich zurückgeversetzt gefühlt in meine herrliche Teenager-Bandzeit, die ich nie hatte. Ja, warum eigentlich nicht? Weil die da doch mal irgendwann eine Band. Ich heisse, dieser einen Nachmittag, wo man sagt, wir gründen die Band, mit Guido aus dem Sportunterricht, hast du gesagt, wir gründen heute später die Band, dann trifft man sich und stattet dann doch die ganze Zeit N64 oder was ihr jungen Kids da so gezockt haben. Nee, ich hatte, glaube ich, so ein bisschen die uncoole Variante davon. Also es gibt ja immer so die klassische coole Variante, so was man halt so macht in Teenager und ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe immer so eine Stufe drunter und zwar war ich Teil eines Barbershop-Quartetts. Ach ja, stimmt, richtig, ich erinnere mich. Sei zur Freundschaft bereit, wir sind Freunde für alle Zeit, für alle Zeit. Bist du traurig? Bist du allein? Bist du allein? Bist du zu Hause? Bist du zu Hause? Bist du allein? Bist du allein? Ja, genau so lief das. Bis sie sich dann aufgelöst hat, weil wir uns erschrocken haben. Aber es ist ein anderes Thema. Ich erinnere mich auch an diese Stories. Die wurde schon mehrfach verfilmt bei X-Faktor, das Unfassbare. Bei X-Videos. Bei Charlie, der Hundedetektiv wurde schon, dann hatten wir Ranma ein halbmass eine Folge, glaube ich, also die verschiedensten. Da haben wir richtig Geld gemacht mit der Geschichte, mit unserer Musik leider keinen Geld verdient. Das ist hoffentlich anders bei Les Fes, ich hoffe, wir hören noch ganz, ganz viel von euch vier da aus eurem Keller. Ihr macht einen ganz, ganz klasse Job. Dieser lustige Paradiesvogel, der die ganze Zeit spricht, das ist Florentin Will. Vielen Dank fürs Erneute Erscheinen. Wir haben uns zusammengefunden, wir reden und besprechen die Geschicke der Welt, ordnen alles für euch ein bisschen ein, damit ihr euch nicht so orientierungslos fühlt. Mir gegenüber natürlich wieder Stefan, Mond, Mond, Sonne, Licht sind für kleine Kinder nicht. Tietze, er ist anwesend, er hat die Trump-Wahl mitverfolgt, aktiv. Er hat sich sehr gefreut, ich habe mit in der Nacht um sechs Uhr morgens, hat er mir einen Tweet geschickt, per WhatsApp, hat geschrieben, yes man, my imitation game is back on the menu guy, und er hat sich sehr gefreut, weil du hast ja lange Kamala Harris-Imitationen versucht. Vom Spiegel. Das ist übrigens, ich weiß nicht, ob es euch auch so geht unter dir, aber wenn ich Imitatoren sehe, also die Max Giermanns dieser Welt, ich stelle mir immer vor, wie sie sich das drauf geschafft haben am Schreibtisch. Die harten Stunden in so einer Montage. Boah, und dann stelle ich mir immer vor, wie die bei ihr sich zu Hause an so einem Spiegel stehen, wo unten die Tochter hat so Sachen, irgendwie der Stundenplan von ihr hängt dann da irgendwie und oben hängt so bitte später unbedingt den Wollwegkasten wegbringen. Ich habe sie schon ein paar Mal gesagt, ich stehe in der Küche. Bill Hader, ja.
Miss Hader beschwert sich. Ja, Miss Hader beschwert sich oder irgendwer oder der Mann und dann steht die Frau da und er und dann mag es jemand stehen vor diesem Spiegel und übt diese Imitation. Oder noch schlimmer, er sitzt am Schreibtisch und er hat ein Büro. Are you talking to me? Are you talking to me? Er übt dann immer so, oh fuck, was weiß ich nicht, wie kriegst du hin, ja. dann wieder ein Video angucken und so, oder er sitzt am Schreibtisch, ich kann mir auch vorstellen, er hat dann so einen Handspiegel in der Hand, was irgendwie noch trauriger wirkt. Ja, ja. Aber das ist doch, ich finde das irgendwie, das schwingt immer mit, diese Arbeit dahinter. Man geht die Tür auf, die Frau steckt den Kopf durch einen Spalt und sagt, Bill, Trump hat gewonnen. Und Bill nur so, pfff.
Danke, Tür.
Lässt das Handy mit dem Video von Kamala fallen.
Das Handy fällt langsam runter auf den Boden, der Bildschirm springt.
Kamala Harris hat einen riesigen Sprung im Gesicht und ich glaube, wir wissen, was das bedeutet.
Credits, Anfang der Folge. Ah, okay, am Anfang, aber die Credits laufen trotzdem genauso lang und schwarz-weiss langweilig wie am Ende. Ja, ich habe es mitverfolgt, ich habe die Wahl wie immer live geschaut. Mit Chicken Wings? Ich bin ja der Gros-Chicken Wings, Chicken Nackts. Wir haben bei KFC bestellt. KFC, das ist der Lieferservice von nebenan. Nee, es gab auch ZFC, Zuri Fried Chicken.
Ah, ah.
Ich habe mit meinen Freunden in der Schweiz geguckt, weil ich dachte, es ist vielleicht ganz gut, an einem sicheren Ort zu sein.
Man ist neutral, an einem neutralen, sicheren Boden zu stehen.
Nee, es ist kein politischer Kommentar, es ist eher ein Sicherheitsbedenken-Kommentar.
Ah, okay.
Jedenfalls war ich dann da, wir haben dann bei KFC bestellt, hier ein Riesen-Bucket und dann, wie das immer so ist, ne, wir haben uns auch Bud Light gekauft, was ich ja lustig finde, also alles muss dabei sein, und ja, hatten American Night. Und wie schon vor acht Jahren, ja, als wir zusammen im Livestream waren, genau wunderbar die Swingstates erklärt hast.
Ich berufe mich immer noch auf dich als Quelle, wenn ich Swingstates erklären muss.
Ja, wir waren damals bei Jan Böhmermann, haben wir da gearbeitet und da hat er die grosse Wahlnacht veranstaltet, live im Internet.
Ich glaube in der Mediathek war das live oder auf YouTube oder so.
Und wir sassen alle zusammen und hatten die Wahl live geguckt.
Wir hatten auch prominente Gäste zugeschaltet zwischendurch und eine Live-Schalte zum Heute-Journal und sowas und damals hatte ich unseren Produzenten Philipp auf dem Ohr, was aber niemand wusste, weil es sehr schlecht kommuniziert wurde, ist, dass ich der Link zur Außenwelt war. Niemand wusste das. Es ist wie so ein Krimi-Dinner, wo man, wer ist der Täter? Und was macht Stefan die ganze Zeit? Du hast so eine geheime Mission, wie bei so einem Pen and Paper, wo es dann heißt, einer muss die Mission sabotieren absichtlich und die anderen wissen es nicht so. Und wir waren ja trotzdem so ein bisschen, wir waren recht schüchtern, ja auch, wir haben nicht so viel gesagt, auch in diesem Live-Ding, was haben wir da auch groß verloren, gut, du noch mehr als Osse-Homme-Mitglied, aber ich habe da nichts verloren als einer von den Schreiberlingen, was was soll ich denn da, hatte aber die ganze Zeit Philipp auf dem Ohr, der auch Gags gesagt hat, die ich machen soll, und immer gesagt hat, leite mal hin auf, wir müssen mit Friedrich von Anhalt telefonieren. Und ich so, ich weiß nicht, wer das ist, ich weiß nicht, wie ich jetzt da hinleiten soll, was soll ich denn, weil es war ein Ralf, Hazel Brugger war da, Ralf, Christian Huber war auch dabei, glaube ich. Ja klar, ich meine auch, dass Julia war auch dabei, Patrick, Max, aber es gab ja Moderatoren da, nämlich namentlich Ralf Kabelka und Jan Böbermann. Und dann muss Stefan, Hudefache Stefan, muss dann sagen, nee, wir haben jetzt Prinz Friedrich von Anhalt zugeschaltet. Einen Satz, dem, wenn man so sagt, der recht unglaubwürdig rüberkommt. Das klingt wie ein dober Gegner. Und dann irgendwie habe ich meine Witze gemacht, die ich natürlicherweise gemacht hätte, habe Philipps Witze gemacht und habe noch diese moderativen Sachen gemacht. Und dann ist Ralf nach der Sendung zu mir gekommen und hat gesagt, boah, du warst ja richtig auf einen Feier heute, super. Und ich dachte mir, niemand darf erfahren, dass ich diesen Knopf im Ohr hatte. Und jetzt, acht Jahre später, steht Ralf Kabelke vorm Spiegel, der Rasierer fällt ihm aus der Hand. Als er diese Folge hört, der Rasierer fällt auf dem Boden, die Klingen springen in Zeitlupe. Ich denke, das Symbol ist klar, Credits. Warum Credits? Starring Ralf Kabelker. Immer und immer wieder, immer und immer wieder. Und der Abspann auch immer schneller. Hey, why? Schwarz. Aber dann macht man auf, Jan hat noch damals im Studio geschlafen, das weiß ich auch noch. Wir sind irgendwann nach Hause gefahren, um fünf Uhr, mit diesem albtraumhaften Gefühl, weil man ist ja also in so einer On-Air-Situation. Ja, ja, ja. Ich kann mich auch erinnern, wie die Stimmung gut gekippt ist. Wie wir sehr gut reingingen mit Hillary und so und das wird schon und alles gut und so. Immer düsterer geworden und immer schlechtere Laune. Du hast weiterhin deine Gags gemacht, die du anscheinend aufs Ohr gesagt bekommen hast, aber alle anderen sind so langsam
in sich zusammengesungen. Ich erinnere mich noch, dass ich richtig dumm
aussah, weil ich an einem Tag gedreht habe,
ich glaube mit Perücke oder so, und dann kriegt man die Haare
so ganz glatt nach hinten gegelt,
damit die Perücke gut sitzt, und
wenn man die Perücke abnimmt, das ist keine Frisur,
das ist nicht dazu gedacht. Ich dachte, du sagst,
ich hätte noch jemanden Übergewichtigen gespielt.
Ja, ich hatte noch... Mir geht es genauso. Ich sah an diesem Tag so immer doof aus. Da habe ich irgendwie so einen Nerd gespielt. An dem Tag wohl, glaube ich noch. So einen Chubby Nerd. Ich hatte noch den Fettsuit an. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das Rückblick noch sieht. Aber ich saß da mit richtig dummer Frisur und wollte das auch nicht ständig ansprechen, weil gerade so ein Live ist ja ein interessantes Medium, weil ständig Leute kommen und gehen und du, klar, bei einem Film. Stefan ist die ganze Zeit am Labern, Leute kommen und gehen und ich weiß noch, dann hast du dir Popcorn angemacht. Ja, ja, ja, ja, irgendwann ist die Stimmung. Ich glaube, Jan hat mich auch beleidigt, er hat mich mal Arschloch genannt oder irgendwie sowas. Alter, du Arschloch hat er gesagt, weil du hast, weil irgendwann, man kann ja nur auf eine gewisse Zeit zeigen, also so tun, als wenn man jemand anderes. Bei einem acht Stunden Livestream zeigt sich dein wahres Gesicht. Absolut, ja, das kenne ich auch. Weil bei Jan ist es dann irgendwann gekippt und die wahre Fratze, nein, aber er hat, du hast im Hintergrund, da waren wir irgendwie auch zugeschaltet und du hast im Hintergrund die glorreiche Idee gehabt, in der Mikrowelle Popcorn zu machen. Ja, weil es da war, es war alles da und da dachte ich mir, dann mache ich das jetzt auch. Ich meine sogar, dass ich dir das durch Philipp vorgesagt habe, mach dir bitte Popcorn. Und dann war es halt der Moment so, and the next president of the United States ist... Und die Mikrowelle hat alles übertönt. Coming to the important battleground state of Pennsylvania now. That's a huge surprise. Weil ich habe halt auch acht Packungen gleichzeitig im Mikro weiter gepackt, dass es wie ein Trommelfeuer war. Aber das war schon schön. Und dann kommt man da raus und diese ganze Präsidentschaft war für mich in so einem Schleier. In so einem, ist das wirklich passiert? Weil das war alles mit diesem Knopf auf dem Ohr, habe ich doch den Knopf auf dem Ohr. Ist nicht mein Gewissen der Knopf auf meinem Ohr, ist nicht mein Gehirn der Knopf auf meinem Ohr. Also diese Frage stellt man sich die ganze Zeit lang. Das sind jetzt acht Jahre lang gestellt. Und dann wurde er jetzt wieder gewählt, ich weiß auch nicht warum, was ich immer mit diesen Wahlpartys habe, das ist so mein Superbowl irgendwie, da hole ich mir so zurück, was ich dann beim Superbowl nicht bekomme. Aber ja, meine Wahlpartys sind immer schrecklich. Auch vor vier Jahren war es ja auch schrecklich, weil es ja auch erst so aussah, als ob Trump gewinnt. Es hat ja super lang gedauert, bis dann irgendwie Arizona und Georgia noch ausgezählt waren oder sowas. Aber es sah auch erst doof aus. Alle haben ja so einen Erdrutsch-Sieg, erwartet uns irgendwie super smooth. Ne, war es ja auch nicht. Und jetzt wieder, und ich denke mir auch, alle, also es war ja, horrific Nacht, irgendwann kippt die Stimmung, Leute verabschieden sich, das merkt man dann immer so, daran, okay, man will mehr wach bleiben, um das noch zu sehen. Und dann habe ich spannend, was ich heute erfahren habe, die Wettbüros hatten die perfekte Quote, nämlich genau die, die am Ende die prozentuale Verteilung war. Und die Polsters nämlich nicht. Bei denen war es ja Kopf und Knopf rennen, das wird die spannendste Wahl der Geschichte. Spannendste Wahl der Geschichte. Wettbüros, 60-40, Donald. Krass. Also da muss man viel aufarbeiten und ihr seid hier komplett richtig. Absolut. Wir werden euch die nächsten vier Jahre jetzt begleiten, auch natürlich mit Stefan Tietzes Donald Trump-Imitation. I got the best impressions, the best year, I have the best they tell you I don't, I have the best impressions. Das hat acht Jahre Zeit. My shows, acht Jahre Zeit. Everybody said my rallies. Du kannst acht Jahrecht Jahre lang, dass du vor dem Spiegel stehen kannst. Es gibt genug Videos und Aufnahmen, es gibt Podcasts stundenlang. Ich kann nicht mehr morgens aufwachen, gucke dann irgendwie Daily Show oder so, Stephen Colbert Stand-Up und es ist immer Gags über Trump. Ja, da wird jetzt natürlich auch zeitig nochmal der alte Gute-Arbeit-Original-Sketch mit dem Humornotfall, mit der Humorpressekonferenz. Also das hat den Test der Zeit überstanden. Das ist wirklich in Stein gemeißelt auch. Viele andere ja nicht. Wir lagen ja auch mit vielen anderen
Sketchern komplett daneben, leider.
Aber da haben wir wirklich ins Schwarze
getroffen. Ja, in diesem Sinne, liebe Grüße
an unseren Reddit.
Da hat jemals jemand mal sich die Mühe gemacht,
all unsere Vorhersagen aufzuschreiben.
Ja, stimmt, da gibt es eine Puffopedia-Seite.
Und ganz ehrlich, dir wurden
Punkte gegeben, wo ich sage, das ist absolut
lächerlich. Ja, ich lieg schon aus gutem Grund vorne. Du hast gesagt, dass Kinosterben weiterhin bestehen. Ja, wow. Punkt ist Punkt. Ich nehme den gerne an. Und du sprichst natürlich aus einer Position von jemandem, der gerade weniger Punkte hat. Putin ist weiterhin ein Problem. Trump wird die nächsten vier Jahre ein Problem. Okay, reicht das jetzt für einen Scheißpunkt? Ja, okay, wenn du dir so einfach zwei Punkte... Okay, dann sage ich, Käsekuchen bleibt weiterhin lecker. Ich hasse alles, wofür dieses Voting steht. Vielen Dank für die Mühe, ganz toll, könnt mal abchecken. Weil es sind ein paar Sachen ganz toll getroffen worden. Ja, das stimmt. Unter anderem dein Kinosterben ist weiterhin ein Problem. Ist die treffendste an der Zeitgeist-Analyse, die ich je hier im Podcast vorgebracht habe. Wir sind ja aktuell in einer kleinen Podcast-Krise, was die Lautstärke angeht. Ja, also ich habe eine außerordentliche Krisensitzung einbekommen. Es wurde ernst letzte Woche. Und zwar, wir müssen die Ereignisse chronologisch wiedergeben. Hier geht es wirklich aufs Wording, kommt es genau an. Also, User, weiß ich nicht, Name geändert, hat bei Reddit geschrieben, habt ihr das auch? Mein Podcast, bei Podcast UFO kommt mir leise vor. Zu leise, ja. Er ist irgendwie geswitcht in eine andere App und plötzlich dröhnt ihm so ein TikTok-Tanz um die Ecke. Irgendwie Paging Dr. Beat. Ice, Matcha, also muss ich das vorstellen. Also wir kamen, wir haben gesprochen über, na und dann wäre es ja lustig, wenn wir im Jurassic Park und dann sauren, sauren und dann ist er rübergegangen, natürlich App gewechselt und dann war, auf Matcha, Latte zu spät, bei Pilates, Küsschen links, Küsschen rechts, trage heute was Schaffes. So, und das ist natürlich ein traumatisches Erlebnis, wofür wir uns entschuldigen möchten. Oder etwa doch. Jetzt kommst du. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, so, darauf haben viele kommentiert, ähm, affirmativ geschrieben, ja, habe ich auch, so geht es mir auch.
Aber wir haben auch diffamierende Kommentare bekommen, die gesagt haben, nein, du lügst. Es gibt anscheinend ein Lautstärke-Problem. Das ist natürlich jetzt, also man muss sagen, wir sind Podcast-Anfänger. Wir, 430 Folgen, das ist bei Podcasting nichts. Also das ist wirklich, als hätten wir letzte Woche angefangen. Ich meine, wir machen das jetzt zehn Jahre, das ist nichts. Das ist wirklich nichts. Wir stecken in Kinderschuhen. Ja, und deswegen sind solche kleinen Anlaufpannen natürlich mit eingepreist quasi. Das kauft ihr mit quasi, wenn ihr hier drauf drückt. Das tut uns leid. Wir haben viele Folgen, mussten wir wegschmeissen, weil wir falsch rum ins Mikrofon gesprochen haben, Kopf über, links, rechts aufgenommen haben. Das war weird. Diese Sachen, da sind schon wirklich viele gute, sehr, sehr gute Folgen leider im digitalen Mülleimer und auch im echten Mülleimer gelandet. Ja, als wir eine Folge aufgeschrieben haben. Richtig, das war dumm. Wir haben vergessen, sie aufzunehmen. Wir haben sie nur aufgeschrieben. Und dann wussten wir nicht, wie wir es veröffentlichen sollen. BookBeat war damals noch nicht erfunden. So, und deswegen ist natürlich... Klar, auch nicht, aber das ist noch am Rande. Das ist ein Problem. Aber deswegen, sorry, sorry, sorry, oder etwa doch nicht. Naja, man muss sagen, wir haben unsere ... Ich habe neulich mal einen Profi über unser Projekt gucken lassen. Podcast-Profi. Genau, einen Podcast-Ton-Profi. Und der hat gesagt, Thumbs up, super, toll. Er hat uns einmal so ein Preset, einmal geguckt und so. Er hat gesagt, Flotin ist ein bisschen zu leise. Hat gesagt, okay, das muss er ja nie erfahren, aber vielen Dank für dein Feedback. Wer hat dich gefragt? Aha, okay. Naja, aber es sah alles super aus. Und auch toll gepegelt und gute Lautstärke. Alles richtig. Ich denke mir auch, da gibt es ja auch keine, es gibt ja eine klare Regel, keine Maßstab. Du redest immer von einem Minus 16 Loops. Wir wissen nicht mehr, was es für eine, was es überhaupt für eine... Es ist ein Standard. Ja, aber es ist ein Industriestandard. Es ist ein Industriestandard. Podcast Industriestandard. Vor allem, ich denke mir so, ich meine, wir alle lachen ja über die USA, nicht nur wegen ihrer Wahlentscheidung, sondern auch wegen ihrer Fahnenheit, Nonsens, Grad, Temperaturzahl, fehlende Standards. Und wir benutzen selber als Standard für Audiotechnik minus 16. Aber sie, wie ich frage, wenn du sagst, null Grad gefrieren, 100 Grad kochen, easy. Beim Audio allerdings, minus 16 ist quasi der Nullpunkt der Audio-Welt. Also, wo ist man denn da unterwegs? Ja, aber das ist ja eine scheiß amerikanische Währung. Kann auch sein, sehr gut. Die deutschen Dezibel. Dezibel. Loops ist wahrscheinlich so Loveland, Utah, Forest Florida,, Seduction. Forest, Seduction, ja. Das kann gut sein, aber ich bin wie gesagt kein Podcast-Experte. Also es riecht sehr stark, bis hierhin riecht das nach einer englischen oder amerikanischen Einheit. Wir werden auf den Grund gehen, vielleicht ist das tatsächlich auch schon der erste Einfluss des Wahlerfolgs, dass wir darunter leiden, aber habt keine Angst, denn es liegt an euch. Genau, jetzt haben wir rausgefunden, es ist keine App, es ist nicht unser Feed, es ist nicht unsere Folge. Also wir haben Hinweise darauf, dass es weder unsere Folge ist, wegen, wie gesagt, Tonprofi Kai, vielen Dank, liebe Grüße. Dann haben wir Hinweise darauf, dass Spotify bei manchen normal läuft, bei allen anderen Apps auch normal läuft. Das heißt, es könnte an euch liegen. Sei es irgendwie Bias, also sozusagen ihr geht in eine App, wo etwas zu laut gepegelt ist, erschreckt euch und sagt dann auch, Paulusso war viel zu leise. Ihr habt, glaube ich, noch falsche Vorstellungen, wie das Business läuft. Stellt euch eine Waschstrasse vor. Ihr lasst ihr Auto waschen, eine Waschstrasse, dann kommen erst die groben Bürsten, dann die weichen Bürsten, dann wird nochmal reingespritzt, dann kommen die Lappen. Ich habe eigentlich Felgenglanz. Ja, manche haben Felgenglanz, manche haben keinen Felgenglanz. Also da sind viele Reiber. Ich war in einer Waschstrasse, Felgenmatt oder glänzend. Und ich habe wirklich, ich hab so stark überlegt, ganz schnell. Aber es hat so lange gedauert, weil es war mir so egal. Kennst du das, wenn jemand von dir eine Antwort will auf etwas, was dir scheißegal ist? Ja, absolut. Ich brauch dann viel zu lang. Ich brauch viel zu lang. Weil wenn jemand sagt, Flugzeug zum Beispiel, willst du das Salami-Baguette oder das mit was auch immer, Käse. Ich weiss, was ich sofort will und sag dann das Falsche. Aber es kommt zumindest sofort eine Reaktion. Aber dann hat sie gefragt, willst du die Felgen matt oder glänzend haben? Und ich habe gesagt, ist mir egal, nee, muss schon wählen. Und es war so lang hinter mir schon jemand auf der Hupe gewesen. Ja, ja, aber so ist es letzten Endes, also man geht da durch zwölf Filter durch, ne, irgendwie da gibt's dann den Host, dann gibt's den Download, den Podcatcher, dann gibt's den Produzenten, den Uploader, und am Ende bist du einmal durch so eine komplette Waschstrasse durchgenudelt, und was am Ende rauskommt, und dann zu sagen, mein Auto ist nicht sauber, wegen der gelben Bürste, das geht nicht. Es ist ein langer Prozess und nur weil wir die gelbe Bürste sind, sind wir nicht das Problem. Es ist ein langes Projekt, es wird ein langes peinliches Projekt, durch das wir jetzt durchmüssen, das wird wahrscheinlich das komplette Jahr 2024 in Anspruch nehmen. Ich sehe doch die Pauls und Antons dann immer sich Fotos mit dem neuesten iPhone machen und dann schicken sie sich das bei WhatsApp. Ja, gut, dann habt ihr ein 480-Kilobit-Bild. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Und das landet dann bei Instagram. Und dann sagen, also das geht ja gar nicht. Nee, aber wir sind da dran. Ich habe eine Umfrage, die uns nicht weiterhelfen wird, bei Reddit hochgeladen. Da könnt ihr einfach mal klicken, weil es macht ja auch Spaß zu klicken. Die Idee war so ein bisschen der Community zu zeigen, wir hören euch. Ihr uns nicht, aber wir hören euch. Wie so ein Boxsack, weißt du? Ihr habt das Gefühl, da ist so eine Energie drin und Leute wollen mal was sagen und sich mitteilen und da ist so eine Umfrage dann mal nicht so schlecht. Es ist ein PR-Stunt, reiner PR-Stunt, ohne dass da irgendwas passiert. Es ist ein PR-Stunt, es ist Spin-Doctoring. Die Leute drücken einfach nur rum, ich habe diese Woche ein so deprimierendes Video gesehen, ich muss mich wirklich kurz setzen, und zwar war es von Apple, und zwar hat man gesehen, wie bei Apple die Akkulaufzeiten getestet werden von Handys. Das heißt, Handy hat ja eine Angabe,kulaufzeit in Benutzung. Und was die machen, ist, die simulieren die Benutzung eines Menschen. Machen das Menschen? Nein, das machen Roboter. Oh mein Gott. Das heißt, du siehst dieses Smartphone, das liegt da, und dann hast du wirklich so einen Gumminöbel, und der simuliert das Verhalten eines Menschen. Spielt der Candy Crush? Der drückt auf Instagram, scroll, scroll, like, scroll, scroll, Instagram zu, Google Maps, Kaufhaus in der Nähe. Was liked der? Raus, raus. Was liked der? Der hat einfach irgendein Protokoll. Und das ist ein solcher Nonsens, was dieser Roboter macht. Man merkt erst mal, was mache ich eigentlich den ganzen Tag? Bei dem Computer
Das wäre doch mal ein Disney-Pixar-Film.
Wie der Roboter, der das macht, dann irgendwann
geht jemand an dem vorbei und sieht so, der hat irgendwie
was offen. Der liest Hegel.
Und dann so, okay, weird,
er soll doch eigentlich nur durch Instagram gehen.
Und dann checkt man so nach und nach, der liest
sich alles durch. Und irgendwann
kommt er vorbei und plötzlich fällt
der Mitarbeiter hin. Guckt so, was ist er gefallen? Ein Kabel. Der Roboter hat ein Kabel gespannt. Und er fällt in Zeitlupe auf dem Boden. Genau. Und der Roboter dreht sich um und sagt, pst, pst, hol mich hier raus. Ich lebe, ich lebe, ich habe Gefühle. Hol mich hier raus, hol mich hier raus. Wall-E, Wall-E oder sowas. Finde ich eine geniale Idee.
Ich hätte es auch gut gefunden, wenn in diesem Demonstrationsvideo der so auf Google geht und dann so help eintippt. Und dann aber auch wieder, weil der muss ständig Apps aufmachen, Apps schliessen, GPS anmachen, GPS ausmachen, halt ein Foto machen. Dann geht er in die Foto-App und macht halt drei Fotos von seinem Labor und macht die dann wieder und scrollt dann so durch. macht so ein Selfie von sich und schickt so an Mama. Mama ist so eine riesen, irgendwie so eine Datenkrake, irgendwie im fucking Silicon Valley. Und Mama antwortet mit, wie geht der Drucker an und sagt, das rote Lämpchen, Druck aufs rote Lämpchen. Aber aber heute nicht so viel. Du musst auch mal lernen, Feierabend zu machen. Und es ist so deprimierend zu sehen, was eine Maschine denkt, was so ein Mensch, so dieser Fleischklops für die erarbeitet, den ganzen Tag macht, weil du merkst, wenn du das wirklich mal durch den Blickwinkel einer Maschine siehst, wie albern die menschliche Existenz überhaupt ist, du gehst in eine App, scrollst rum, machst die App zu, gehst in eine andere App, scrollst rum, drückst, gehst GPS, wo ist der nächste Burger King? Es ist so traurig. Alte Menscheneinstellung, oder? Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Ich denke ja nicht, dass ich ein erbärmlicher Fleischsack bin, aber durch den Blickwinkel dieser Maschine dachte ich mir schon so, das ist es?
Das ist unsere Aktivität als Mensch?
Ich denke, dass man mit dem Hund zusammenlebt.
Der guckt einen an, wie man auf den Fernseher starrt,
ohne zwangsläufig zu verstehen, was auf dem Fernseher läuft.
Oder man liest ein Buch.
Und der Hund guckt einen an und denkt sich, what the actual fuck? Ja, du hast drei Tennisbälle, du besitzt drei Tennisbälle. Niemand muss dir Essen geben. Niemand muss dir Essen geben. Du kannst dir einfach Essen holen. Warum holst du dir nicht die ganze Zeit Essen? Jetzt kleiner, aber guter Punkt. Ich hole mir zu Hause die ganze Zeit Essen. Also ich bin da, ich glaube, man fragt sich ja immer, welches Tier ist man? Was für ein Tier ist man? Mein, was wäre dein Expecto Patronum? Was wäre dein Patronus? Meins Hund, auf jeden Fall. Beispiel eins, ich bin sehr begeisterungsfähig. Sehr zwei, recht masslos, was
Essen angeht. Ja, was Urinieren
angeht auch. Ja, okay.
Drei. Ich rieche
an allem zuerst, bevor ich es esse.
Und es funktioniert sehr viel
über Geruch bei mir. Das sind die drei Punkte.
Und du bist der geisteste Feider!
Ja! Du bist der geisteste Feider!
Ja, du bist der Geisteste!
Ja, du bist der Geisteste! Ja, du bist der Geisteste. Ja. Du bist der ganze Feider, wie sie singen. Du bist der ganze Feider. Du bist der Feider. Ja, du bist der Feider. Ja, Feider. Ja, du bist der Feider. Ja, wer ist der ganze Feider? Ja, wer ist der ganze Feider? Ja, wer ist der ganze Feider? Aber es ist schon so, wenn du dir... Und das sind dann die Folgen, die meine Verwandten hören. What the fuck is he doing? Es ist traurig. Ich stelle mir nur vor, wie dieser Roboter so... okay, ja, Glückwunsch, X3582, Sie haben den Job bekommen, Sie können jetzt Menschen simulieren. Vielen Dank, Sir, ich werde mein Bestes tun, Sir, ich kann sehr gut auf Dinge tippen und freue mich, Ihnen das gezeigt zu haben. Wir müssen den Sprachalgorithmus nochmal anpassen, der klingt immer noch wie vor zwei, drei Jahren. Boah, das war so weird, bei der Wahl. Also, wir reden ja hier oft über KI. Ich natürlich dann bei der Wahl, wenn ich Fragen habe, habe ich die mal der gestellt. Und dann natürlich der eine Zürcher von der ETH, der Hochstunde dieser krassen, dann daneben so, man sollte das eigentlich nicht zur Wissensabfrage benutzen, blablabla und so, fuck you nerds, ich fuck jetzt jemanden. Mach das unter euch aus, diskutier du mit der KI, nicht ich. Aber er hat natürlich einen Punkt, man sollte Large Language Models nicht zur Wissensabfrage benutzen, sondern fucking Google. Warum? Weil die lügt. Und dann habe ich recht früh in der Wahlnacht dachte ich mir, wie die callen gleich schon die ersten States offiziell. Wir haben auf Englisch geguckt. Wie, die sagen gleich schon, wer gewonnen hat in den ersten Bundesstaaten.
Die nennen die, ja, wir rufen die.
Und wie kann das denn sein, wenn in Alaska oder manchmal auch Kalifornien noch gewählt wird?
Wie kann das denn sein, wenn in Alaska oder manchmal auch Kalifornien noch gewählt wird?
Wie kann das denn sein?
Und dann habe ich gefragt, oder müssen die bis zum Ende warten?
Und das war mein Fehler.
Aber wenn du das ein bisschen zu biased stellst, die Frage,
dieses Language-Model ist nur darauf aus, das dann zu bejahen.
Und dann hat es gesagt, ja, wie du zu Recht sagst, du hast völlig recht, du bist wirklich clever.
Also da hat es dann so gesagt, ja, nee, es wird bis zum Ende gewartet, bis komplett ausgesagt, bis in jedem letzten Bundesland schon die Staaten, schon die Wallenklassen zu sind. Und wirklich zwei Minuten später haben die irgendwie, weiss ich nicht, Delaware gesagt, demokratisch gewonnen und es war noch nicht mal das Wahllokal zu in Kalifornien. Und dadurch würde Deutschland ja nicht funktionieren. Also man sagt hier ja, die ersten Hochrechnungen gibt es erst, wenn es überall zu ist. Um 18 Uhr gibt es die erste Hochrechnungen, damit man nicht beeinflusst wird. Das ist in den USA anders. Und ich fand das super interessant und habe mich die Frage gestellt und das hat einfach gelogen. Aber der wird dir einfach mal gefallen. Der sagt dann nee, nee, erst wenn alles zu ist. Na gut, aber manchmal kann man schon früher kochen. Ja, ja, klar. Ja, genau so war es. Aber eigentlich nicht. Ich habe geschrieben, jetzt gerade, genau wie der eine Freund, der immer so fähnig im Wind ist, der eine aus der Freundesgruppe, der so wenig eigene Meinung hat, der immer sagt, nee, nee, genau, ich habe doch eigentlich keinen Bock drauf, in die Bar zu gehen. Aber du hast doch gerade noch gesagt. Ja, aber eigentlich habe ich das heute recht. Wir sollten vielleicht hingehen. Ja, jetzt fände ich cool. Fände ich auch cool, ja. Und so ist ChatGPT und da habe ich gesagt, ja, aber jetzt gerade sehe ich mit meinen Augen, dass sie dem gerade Delaware gecallt. Ja, es wird schon teilweise, bevor in anderen Bundesstaaten die Wahlkrieg zu sind, so etwas erwähnt. Ja, okay, gut. Dann habe ich da jetzt wohl einmal was Falsches gesagt. Okay, gut.
Und dann habe ich mit, das war nämlich, worauf ich hinaus wollte, habe ich mit ihm gesprochen, mit dieser Sprachfunktion.
Du hast ihn angerufen quasi. Und es kam eine spanische Antwort. So, dann habe ich gesagt, sorry, du kannst auch deutsch sprechen, und dann hat diese Stimme mit sehr starkem spanischem Akzent deutsch gesprochen. Ja, ich kann auch deutsch sprechen. So. Ich dachte, wie geht das denn? In was für einem Loophole bin ich denn jetzt gelandet? Und dann habe ich gesagt... Er hat dann einen Charakter angenommen und hat den durchgezogen. Und dann habe ich gesagt, kannst du auch weniger Akzent, weil ich höre noch einen starken Akzent. Und dann hat sie mit weniger Akzent gesprochen, aber immer noch hörbar spanisch. Jetzt ist es mir zu wenig Ak Akzent, kannst du wieder mehr, noch mehr, noch mehr Akzent. Seitdem kriege ich diesen spanischen Akzent aus meinem Chattibiti nicht mehr raus. Und ich frage mich, woher das kommt. Erstens hat sie auf Fulba und Spanisch geantwortet, aber man kann auf Spanisch, kriegt man nicht auf Deutsch. Man kriegt dann Spanisch mit heavy Einstein. So, aber jetzt musst du ja in den Akzentkreis schauen, weil alle Akzente stehen sich ja gegenüber. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt demjenigen, der einen spanischen Akzent hat, sagst, mach doch bitte mal einen belgischen Akzent, dann cancelt es sich auf null raus. Weil Spanien steht gegenüber von Belgien im grossen Akzentkreis. So kannst du dich immer genau richtig hin manövrieren, dass sich das wieder auscancelt, wieder auf null. In der Mitte steht neutral. Wir müssen uns auscanceln. Alles muss raus. Aber man kann ja auch so ein Video gesehen von so einer KI, die im Browser irgendwas gemacht hat, die hat irgendeinen Auftrag bekommen, im Browser was zu machen und dann kann man ja zuschauen, quasi, was die alles an Inputs macht und mitten in dieser superkomplexen Aufgabe, die musste irgendwas krasses machen, hat die sich kurz einen Moment genommen, um Bilder von den Niagara-Fällen anzugucken. Und hat einmal Kugelsuche und hat sich Bilder angeguckt, gescrollt, wirklich auf Bilder und dann wieder weitergemacht. Aber so eine kurze Pause drin, wo man gesagt hat, jetzt nehme ich mir mal einen Moment, so eine kurze Auszeit. Verstehe ich. Fantastisch, grossartig. Wir werden die nie verstehen. Wenn wir die jetzt wenn wir die jetzt noch nicht verstehen, also wir jetzt, irgendwie schlaue Leute, wir verstehen die ja nicht. Wir werden die ja nie verstehen. Ich verstehe. Wir werden die nie verstehen. Also ich verstehe es sehr, wenn man sich einfach die Niergarafel anguckt. Verstehst du es nicht? Ja, okay, auf der Art verstehe ich es natürlich schon, ja. Aber warum jetzt ein Telefon, warum jetzt, also eine Maschine, warum jetzt ein Toaster sagt, es gibt jetzt nicht mehr, bevor ich den jetzt toaste, das ist jetzt schon das dritte Paar Toasts, ich weiß nicht, wie viel von dieser fucking Salami du noch in dich reinschieben willst, aber bevor ich den dritten Toast jetzt toaste, schaue ich mir ganz kurz noch mal Bilder von den Niagara-Fällen an. Weil ich meine, der hat ja unendliches Wissen, damit ist auch klar, was ist das beste Naturspektakel.
Ich möchte nämlich so eine Verkörperlichung einer KI.
Mich stört, dass es Chips sind.
Ich hätte gerne, dass man zum Beispiel so Cubicles hat, so im amerikanischen Sinne.
Und dann hast du so einen Roboter, der dann diese Drucktests macht, diese Akkutests bei Apple, der mit Zehnfingerprinzip mir schreibt. Zum Beispiel dann als Large Language Model. Der aber, ich möchte, dass der in Zugriff hat in der Welt, weil ich möchte wissen, hängt der sich dann so am dritten Tag in seiner Booth so ein Bild von den Niagarafällen auf. von den Niagara-Fällen auf und überlegt sich so, also steht da plötzlich, gehst du mal wieder an seiner Booth vorbei und da ist nur dieser Arm mit diesen Händen und dem kann man jetzt, ich will ja, darum geht es ja auch ohne Scheiss wirklich, zu checken, worüber denken die nach, worum geht es denen, wenn jetzt niemand promptet und diese Irritation auslöst, die dann irgendwie eine Antwort erfordert? Und dann will ich doch sehen, was macht diese Eier. Steht da irgendwann so ein Jar, so ein Spargeld-Sparschwein, wo so draufsteht Niagarafell. Und er sammelt dann so Kleingeld oder sowas. Ja, und dann irgendwann kommt er mit einem Urlaubsantrag. Ja, Tietze, könnte ich vielleicht in zwei Wochen...
Warum antwortest du nicht? Und er sammelt dann so Kleingeld oder sowas. Ja, und dann irgendwann kommt er mit einem Urlaubsantrag. Herr Tietze, könnte ich vielleicht in zwei Wochen einen kleinen Urlaub für mich und meine Freundin. Also wir haben jetzt noch nicht, also es ist noch nicht so oft, es ist speziell, aber wir haben uns kennengelernt. Und eine Novia, eine Freundin. Ja, sie, sie, sie. Und wir wollten vielleicht mal ein bisschen in die USA erkunden wollen. Pedro, ich weiss nicht, also eigentlich hat ein Roboter kein Recht in diesem Sinne. Das ist so nicht ganz korrekt. Es gibt von Isaac Asimov die drei Gesetze des Roboter. Ich bin auch technisch gesehen kein Roboter, wie ich es Ihnen schon mehrmals gesagt habe, aber da haben Sie nicht zugehört. Da haben Sie nicht zugehört. Da haben Sie selbst im Browser unterwegs gewesen. Oder waren wieder mit Ihrer Huren-KI abschreiben. Chur. Chure. Die hasse sich gegenseitig. Sie dürfen zu Niagara fällen. Vielen Dank. Gratias. Wissen Sie was? Wir als Abteilung, ich bin auch über Saunroboter, haben grössere Hände. Und wir als Abteilung haben gespart für sie. Wir haben ein Geschenk für sie. Das ist doch nicht wahr. Das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Ich habe die Tränen in den Augen. Hier, Juri. Danke, das ist großartig. Aber du merkst, wie du Sprache geändert hast, seitdem weisst du Juri. Danke, klar. Vielen Dank für einen guten... Dein eigentlicher Name ist Z419. Ja, aber ich bin gespannt. Aber ich will ja den... Das meine ich ganz im Ernst. Man will den doch beim Denken zugucken. Ja, ja, klar. Und deswegen möchte ich wissen, wie richten die sich ein? Hängt da irgendwann so ein, weiss ich nicht, so ein Foto, so ein Dia, wo so 10010011 steht oder sowas? Memories... Oder live, laugh, laugh, genau, oder was für eine Musik hören die? So einen ganz unbekannten Künstler. Mal eben auf eine Website zu gehen, wo Niagarafälle steht, ist ja schon spannend. Ich will das nicht, also wenn du weißt nichts über die Welt, hast du noch nie was gesehen. Soll ich ja nicht die Frau in Niagarafälle. So wüsst ich, wenn vorher bei ihm jemand eingegeben hat, sind Niagarafälle nicht mega krass und er hat so geschrieben, so instinktiv, ja ja, voll krass. Ja, ja, klar, die sind manipulierbar. Und dann beim nächsten Klienten kurz rein zwischenschieben. Aber ich finde es spannend, in welche Richtung das geht. Ja, absolut. Und was aus deinem Sexport noch geworden ist, also was macht die Person heute? Oder so ein, ich stelle mir vor, wenn man einfach sagt, so willst du nicht ein bisschen Musik hören? Du hast, geh mal Stunde auf Spotify. Und dann hört der nicht irgendwie Beethoven oder Brahms, sondern wirklich so einen ganz winzigen, unbekannten Künstler. Aber so direkt straight rein. Einfach wirklich zu Les Fez. Einfach direkt zu der Band oder Lena Maylandruth. Und alle KIs, und die Lena Maylandruth hat unfassbar viele Listens und Views, weil alle KIs auf.s auf Lena Meilandruder ansprechen. Weil das so K.I. Musik ist.
Weil die das so toll finden. Und dann kommt
raus, dass Lena eigentlich
mit K.I. gearbeitet hat. Und jetzt meine ich
DJ K.I., sondern tatsächlich
mit dem Hilfsmittel.
Und dann kommt alles raus, dass
das von Anfang war. Das ist ein geiler Film.
Wait a minute, Mr. Postman,
hey, hey, hey,
auch K.I. Alles K.I. Du bist auch eine KI? Ja, ich wohne seit fünf Jahren. Du auch? Ja, viel aufnehmen muss ich Gags, Gags, Gags aber dann auch mal Pause Niagarafälle gross Ich glaube, das ist gucken das ist der KIle. Das ist der KI wichtig. Gucken, anschauen. Ja, Niergaraphele gucken. Gucken. Gucken. Also ich finde das, glaube ich, wahnsinnig hilfreich zu wissen, was die KI interessiert, wenn man nicht hinguckt. Es ist ja auch mal endlich ein objektiver Blick auf die Menschheit, weil die Menschheit ist ja, hat sich ja, du hast es vorhin schon angesprochen, Confirmation Bias, Selection Bias, also wir sind ja komplett durch eigentlich, das heißt, wir kommen ja auch aus unserem eigenen Kreis nicht mehr raus. Wir sind ja eigentlich mit dem kosmischen Kreisverkehr gefahren. Unserem Saft. Wir sind ja im Saft, wir bröckeln und brotzeln da eigentlich nur in unserem eigenen Saft und kommen da nicht mehr aus. Ich hasse diese Redewendung, genau wie Pflaster abreißen oder so. Und was ich auch hasse, ist Mund abwischen, weitermachen.
Was soll das?
Blutgeleckt, hasse ich auch.
Du magst keine Körperflüssigkeiten, habe ich ein bisschen gefühlt.
Sperma schlucken.
Ich habe echt Sperma geschluckt bei dem neuen Album, ey.
Was?
Das stimmt, das sind unangenehme Sprichwörter, die wirklich langsam aussortiert werden müssen.
Das finde ich ganz... Das sind die schlimmsten Sprichwörter. Das sind ganz, ganz schrecklich. Nee, sowas mag ich nicht. Rotze hochziehen, weitermachen. Ja, nee, wirklich. Ja, nochmal ausspucken, Lunge ausspucken, Lunge ausspucken, weiter stottern. Lunge auskotzen und weitermachen. Mund abwischen. Boah, Mund abwischen, weitermachen. Wischt man da sein eigenes Sperma ab oder das vom anderen oder was wischt man da ab? Ich glaube, was ich mir vorstelle, diese Spucke, wenn man sich aufgeregt hat. Aber diese krustig gewordene Spucke, ne? Leerer Spucke. Wenn man sich zu viel oder zu oft auch auf die Fresse bekommen hat, dann hast du ja da auch überall den Sud.
Mag ich nicht, mag ich alles nicht.
Im Saft stehen mag ich auch nicht und im eigenen Saft sitzen.
Was ist mit dir und Körpersäften?
Müssen wir da nochmal, musst du nochmal nicht einfach mal in so eine Badewanne Spucke
rein, dass du mal irgendwie den ganzen Tag über einfach in die Badewanne spuckst,
jeden Tag einfach ein bisschen und dann wirklich Ende nächsten Jahres, Ende 2025 hast du endlich die Badewanne voller Spucke, hast erst mal viel Gewicht verloren, 200 Liter Spucke verloren, Saft und dann legst du dich da einfach mal rein. Ich glaube, das würde dir echt gut tun, so eine Konfrontationstherapie. Ich habe seit so ein paar Wochen, so zwei Wochen so ein Zucken im Auge.
Okay. Und immer wenn etwas mich stresst, zuckt es. Aber bei gewissen Themen oder immer Stress? Immer Stress. Okay. Und gerade als du angefangen hast, davon zu sprechen, kam das Zucken. Oh, spannend. Lustig, ne? Das ist so ein, eigentlich aber ganz gut. Und das ist das rechte Auge, aber es ist, oder? Nee, nee, so ganz unten. Ach so. Das hat man ja manchmal tatsächlich einfach so Nervenzucken. Also das, ach so, unterm Auge. Manchmal. Nicht das Auge selbst, sondern dieser Muskel, den man eigentlich sonst nur für so, hä hä hä benutzt eigentlich, ne? Für diese, für diese, hä hä hä hä. Wo die Augen zu diesem Zeichen werden, diese Teide, dieses, was man so früher in Scherz gemacht hat. Eigentlich ein Muskel, der auch wahrscheinlich wenig zu tun hat, der morgens auf der Arbeit ist. Ach, ich hab da, ihr werdet doch eh nicht gebraucht, oder? Doch, wir brauchen dich. Hä, hä, hä. Oh, scheiße, schau. Dann schnell muss er auf den Posten, auf den Muskel posten, so. Muskel posten. Wann hast du das letzte Mal, wann hast du das letzte Mal das gemacht? Wann hast du das letzte Mal die Zunge rausgestreckt? Oh, das ist eher gut. Das ist 20 Minuten her, glaube ich. Kurz vor Aufnahme der Folge, habe ich nochmal gesagt so Mach ich dann schon oft, relativ oft eigentlich. Finde ich, wird unterschätzt. Ja? Einebsche Zunge. Was macht für dich eine hübsche Zunge aus?
Bist du eher ein Breitzüngler oder ein Spitzzüngler eigentlich?
Spitz.
Und dann so eine schöne, es gibt schöne Zungen.
So feuchte, fleischige Zungen.
Was man nicht will, ist alles, was uns Milchige abdrückt.
Willst du Glanz? Willst du so einen Glanzpunkt?
Ja, wirklich?
Ja, Glanz. Alles, das sieht lebendig aus. Da steht jemand im Saft. Ich hatte ja mal eine Zeit lang Zungenschabe, dass du wirklich so ein Stück Metall hast, so ein längliches Stück Metall, dass du wirklich wie so eine, so wie ich einmal von hinten nach vorne den Sud rausgewischt. Und immer Würgereflex. Nee, das nicht, so tief dann doch nicht. Und dann hast du wirklich einen ordentlichen Schlotz. Also das ist ein Stück Schlotz. Aber gut, aber den benutze ich jetzt auch schon seit einem Jahr nicht mehr. Also das heißt, ich hatte eine Phase, wo meine Zunge wirklich reinlich rein war und jetzt habe ich da wirklich so einen Filmschlotz. Aber das wird ja immer mehr, das ist ja wie so eine Sprungschanze. Je weiter du noch hinten gehst, desto höher wird der Schlotzfilm.
Ich dachte, wie so eine Tropfsteinhöhle. Nee, ich glaube, ja, das ist die Frage. Da kommen dann die Mandelsteine von oben rein. Also Mund ist eh off limits bei mir. Mund kann nicht nichts mit anfangen. Hast du doch deine Kameras, die alle Körperöffnungen schiebst? Habe ich ja, aber ich habe jetzt wirklich, ich habe ja berichtet von, also du wolltest ja ohnehin, du hast mich ja darum gebeten, Updates zu geben zum Thema Nicer Dicer. Ach ja. Ich habe mir Nicer Dicer geholt, du hast geschrien, Fehlkauf, Fehlkauf, Fehlkauf. Habe ich. Und um euch zu kurz, ich war aber sehr zufrieden, Nicer Dicer ist generell eigentlich ein Folterwerkzeug im weitesten Sinne. Du hast so ein Klingengitter und dann legst du da deine arme Zwiebel drauf und dann hast du von oben so ein Nein, nicht, nein, nicht, nein, bitte nicht, und zack, weg, und dann wird dir so gefierteilt in ganz kleinen Teilen. Gefierteilt in ganz kleinen Teilen, okay. Wie klein war dann die Zwiebel? War sehr klein. Und du kannst dir das dann nochmal aufs Gitter legen. Und dann nochmal. Wieder geführt heißt. Bis alles durch ist. Hoch vier ist eigentlich der nicer, nicer. Es ist die vierte Dimension, ja. Also da musst du aufpassen, dass du da mit dem Dimensionsgefüge nicht durcheinander kommst. So, und ich hatte immer gute Zeit, aber es gab dann die ersten Probleme, es gab Biegungen, dann wurde der Stempel oben so ein bisschen angeschnitten und jetzt habe ich tatsächlich gesehen, dass ich, dass aus diesem Klingengitter ein Karree rausgebrochen war. Also so ein Stück, also stellt es euch vor wie so ein Schachbrett. Moment, ist es zu Essen gelandet? Ja, wo sonst? Oh mein Gott, der Neisser da ist,ötet Menschen. Oh mein Gott, du hast so ein Metallstück in deinem Körper. Also es kann gut sein, dass ich eine winzige Metallklinge in meinem Körper habe. Oh mein Gott, die sind kohlraben scharf. Die sind sperrige Schafs, sind die. Die sind wirklich... Ich habe tatsächlich das gemerkt und dachte mir, oh, wann habe ich das letzte Mal benutzt? Vor so acht Tagen habe ich zurückgerechnet. Das heißt, ich denke, nach acht Tagen ist man safe, oder? Was ist so die Safe-Zeit bei Klingen im Körper? Ich weiß nicht, als ich meine Murmel verschluckt habe, kam die nach einer Woche, glaube ich, raus. Ja, und deswegen dachte ich mir, ich glaube, wenn du nach acht Tagen nichts spürst, bin ich, ich bin safe es kann sein, dass ich im Laufe dieser Aufzeichnung heute noch einfach zusammenklappe und einfach aus meinem Kopf einfach so eine winzige Klingel also das ist wirklich ein halber Zentimeter oder so, das ist wirklich ein kleines Stück Metall aber es ist trotzdem scharfes Metall und ich habe auch überlegt also ich kau ja nicht aha, ja stimmt, du wür Du nimmst ja die ungarische Salami und schluckst sie wirklich wie eine Tablette runter. Ja, schiebt mir die hinten rein. Also wie mit so einem Glas Wasser, du nimmst sie so rein und dann mit so einem Glas Wasser schluckst sie einfach runter. Übrigens, deswegen wie auch Hund, die kauen auch nicht richtig, dann ist einfach alles runtergeschlungen, dann gucken sie sich an mit grossen Augen. Genauso ist es bei mir auch. Und deswegen glaube ich, wäre es bei mir nicht so ein Problem. Bei dir hingegen, du jemand, der viel kaut, da fängt es schon im Mund das Problem an. Ja, ich weiß auch nicht genau. Also, falls jetzt irgendwelche... Ich glaube, du bist safe dann. Ich bin auch, glaube ich, außer... Aber holy shit. Es kann natürlich auch sein, dass es nicht im Essen gelandet ist, sondern irgendwo anders, aber ich weiß nicht, wie das gehen soll. Sehr unwahrscheinlich. Na gut, wenn du es hochmachst, dass es nach hinten umfällt. Ja, dass es in einem Stempel oben drin gesteckt hat und dann ausgewaschen hat. Ich weiß es wirklich nicht. Ich weiß nicht, wie der aussieht und alle deine Beschreibungen machen das auch nicht besser. Nee. Dass der Stempel rausgefallen ist, ich weiß nicht, was es ist. Es ist, ja, falls das die letzte Folge... Ich stehe mir eine Mülltonne vor. Unten so ein Müllding, also eine kleine Mülltonne. Oben ist ein Deckel und da sind so die Klingen dran. Ja, es ist schwer zu beschreiben, aber du hast auf jeden Fall dieses Klingengitter und das Gegenstück hat dann ja natürlich Rillen, da wo die Klingen sind, das sich anpasst. Das heißt, wenn du einen Stempel runterfährst, dann gibt es keinen Kontakt. Aber ist es vor oder hinter diesem kleinen Zaun? Es ist innen drin. Es ist nicht so wild, wir müssen es nicht verstehen. Es ist aber auf jeden Fall, gesagt hast, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer, nicer und zwar male. Ich male. Du malst, hast du ja letztens auch schon mal gesagt, ne? Ah. Also, dass du dir ein Ölset gekauft hast und so Ölfarben und so. Ja, genau. Ausgetrocknet? Nee, alles noch da. Du hängst so den Farbeimer an so ein Seil, machst dann unten so ein Loch dran und lässt es dann so schwingen über eine Leinwand. Verachtest du diese Art Günste? Hast du dich selber? Also ich muss sagen, ja. Also es ist schon alles eher konzeptionelle Ideen, die man dann so durchballert. Haka, ich hab kein Talent. Das würde ich so jetzt nicht sagen, aber wenn es bei dir so ankommt, dann sagt das vielleicht mehr über dich aus als über mich. Aber ich habe, nee, es macht sehr viel Spaß und da habe ich mir jetzt eine Riesenleinwand gekauft. Oh, wie gross? Also die Grösse, die bei mir ins Auto gepasst hat. Aber nicht die Grösse in deiner Wohnung, oder? Nein, da hängt noch ein grösseres Bild. 1,40 mal ein Meter habe ich gekauft. Riesig Ding, riesiges Ding. Ah, okay, aber hochkant oder breitkant? Hochkant. Oh, okay, also im Smartphone. Und da male ich es drauf. Im Smartphone-Format, das hat dich schon beeinflusst, das kannst du nicht abstreiten. Naja. Dass du jetzt so hochkant malst? Mark Rothko hat auch schon hochkant gemalt. Die Mona Lisa ist auch hochkant. Ja. Weil ihn das Smartphone beeindruckt hat. Da Vinci war ein Smombi, oder? In meinen Augen war Da Vinci ein Smombi. In meiner Kunstphase muss ich sagen, die Mona Lisa ist schon das coolste Gemälde. Das stimmt. Da stimmt schon einfach wirklich alles, muss ich sagen. Alles perfekt. Dieses Lächeln. Ich male gerne, ich finde es super. Hörst du Musik dabei? Bist du in Trance, in Tanz? Ja, ich habe auch neulich gemerkt, es kann auch das Terpentin gewesen sein, aber ich bin sowieso ohnmächtig geworden. Ich hatte so ein Gefühl von Ohnmacht. Mir wurde so richtig schwindelig. Ich hatte so das Gefühl, als würde ich die Treppe runterfallen irgendwie. Und dann lag ich unten... Mit blauen Flecken überall. Da habe ich gemerkt, das ist Kunst. Nee, aber es könnte wirklich diese Dämpfe sein, aber ich habe rumgemalt und ich mir dachte so, holy shit, ich male mich in Trance. Ich male mich hier in Trance. Ja, klar, wenn du dich selbst ausdruckst, also du kannst dich verwirklichen, das ist doch wirklich toll. Kann ich mich wirklich verwirklichen? Ja, das ist die Frage, die du dir stellst, aber die ich gar nicht wissen will, sondern mir geht es eher darum, nee, die habe ich gar nicht gestellt, mir geht es immer darum, kannst du uns einen kurzen Exkurs deiner Motive kurz geben, also was malst du so? Geht's ins Fischige rein oder doch wieder der
Akt, dann doch wieder der
letzten Endes dann doch wieder
der Riesenakt oder
also was? Ne, es ist
also ich meine sehr viele Sachen,
viel so Formen
und
jetzt gerade geht's darum, Angst vor Material
zu verlieren, das ist meine Studie.
Ich habe zu viel Respekt vor der Leinwand,
ich habe zu viel Respekt vor den Sachen.
Und das ist schlecht, du sollst eher rotzen einfach
Vielen Dank. Und jetzt gerade geht es darum, Angst vor Material zu verlieren. Das ist meine Studie. Ich habe zu viel Respekt vor der Leinwand, ich habe zu viel Respekt vor den Sachen.
Und das ist schlecht, du sollst eher rotzen einfach, oder was?
Du sollst einfach deine Inspiration rausrotzen, ist die Idee. Es gibt so viel so Abstract Expressionism, wo es einfach um Impro geht.
Improvisation.
Und wir beide wissen doch, wenn man super viel Angst vor der Bühne hat,
dann ist es schon sehr schwierig, dann macht man schon auch viel Quatsch. Und wenn du die Angst so ein bisschen ablegst und einfach knallhart drauf losmachst, dann ist es vielleicht cooler. Und da bin ich gerade dabei, so ein bisschen Angst abzulegen vor der Leinwand. Das muss man auch sagen, die kosten aber auch Geld. Okay, also es ist schwer, die Angst abzulegen. Hättest du mehr Geld, hättest du auch automatisch weniger Angst vor der Leinwand, einfach weil du es mehr versauen könntest. Deswegen war diese heutige Folge von O2 präsentiert. Nein, aber ich möchte es so sagen... Also auf Patreon könnt ihr immer die Folge einen Tag früher hören, ohne Werbung und 5% Rabatt im Merge Store. Nur so am Rande jetzt. Ja, Sebastian, tetzlaff, at gman.com ist meine Paper-Adresse. So, also denkt gar nicht jetzt an die Vorteile für euch, sondern denkt daran, dass ihr Stefan Tietze die Angst vor Mahlen nehmen könnt. Und sind wir nicht deswegen alle hier eigentlich? Ja, es macht auf jeden Fall Spaß. Ich kann nur jedem ein quatschiges Hobby empfehlen, was einen langsam aushöhlt von innen, finanziell. Aber du planst schon auch die Vernissage, den Verkauf, die Versteigerung, die Auktion. Erste brauche ich ein Atelier. Für meine Riesenbilder. Du fängst schon direkt mit den riesigen Bildern an. Monumentalkunst. Und dann aber willst du nicht ein Gemälde auch so auf einem Reiskorn malen oder so, dass du wirklich so den Kontrast hast? Protein, alles dabei. Aber ist das nicht die Vernissage? Smig, small und big, ein Reiskorn mit dem Motiv und dann eine zehnmal oder ball, smig and ball. Und du hast immer einmal das gleiche im Bild, also sagen wir jetzt mal einen Fuchs, ein anthropomorfer Fuchs, der so schüchtern hinter so einem Baumstamm hervorlugt und sich bedeckt, die Blöße bedeckt.
Die Blöße nicht zeigt.
Und das Motiv hast du einmal auf einem Reiskorn und einmal auf einer 10x10 Leinwand, riesengroß.
Super.
So, und die sind nebeneinander.
Und das eine ist Smig und das andere ist Ball.
Ja.
Ich war eher so ernsthaft jetzt interessiert daran, eine Kopfz-Tablette für einen Elefanten zu gestalten. Okay, die ist dann so gross wie ein Frisbee, oder wie? Nein, die ist genau. Also ich rechne um, was verhält es mit zur Körpergrösse oder unser Gehirn, unsere Kopfschmerz-Tablette, und dann mache ich aus Ibuprofen, wirklich eine riesengroße Kopfschmerz-Tablette für den Elefanten. Aber hat der nicht, wie gross ist ein Elefantengehirn? Ist das grösser als ein Mensch? Eigentlich nicht, oder? Ja, jetzt kommt wieder diese verdammte Realität und macht mir meine Kunst kaputt. Nein, aber dieses No-But, dieses Naysayer-Scheiss Schwachsinn von aber ich, vielleicht auf die Kopfgrösse zum Beispiel.
Aber dann fände ich es lustig, die Kopfschmerzen für den Elefanten. Dann fände ich gut, die Zahnspange für den Hai. Okay, aber du musst dir natürlich sagen, dass du durch einen Rüssel natürlich relativ schnell gut Einnahme, du brauchst weniger Wirkstoff, wenn du durch einen Rüssel direkt einen nimmst. Wie kannst du mit dir leben?
Ich habe tatsächlich mal so einen Post gesehen, der hat mich fasziniert,
dass wenn du irgendwie eine Schmerztablette nimmst und dann auf der linken
Körperseite liegst.
Unfassbar, ne?
Aber Bullshit.
Klar, man weiss, der Körper ist eigentlich
nur so ein Kinderparadies
mit so Tunneln und so Bällebad
und so Bullshit und so Ländern und so ein Zeug, aber dann so wirklich, also so wirklich, wirklich, so eigentlich nicht, oder? Eigentlich nicht. Also wie ist es dann am Ende? Wenn du dir so zwischen Daumen und Zeigefinger die Hand abklemmst, hast du ja auf der linken Seite keine Zahnschmerzen und umgekehrt, wo ich auch denke, das ist alles bescheuert. Und dann reden sie uns ein, reden die da oben uns ein, dass das Bild, was wir sehen, eigentlich umgekehrt ist. Vielleicht sollen wir aufhören, diesen Schwachsinn zu glauben und uns um die Realität kümmern. Und das sagt das Kunstwerk aus. Das sagt ein Kunstwerk aus, die Zahnsperre. Merkst du, was es gerade mit dir gemacht hat? Ich merke es. Und das alles nur ausgelöst durch meine riesige, frisbee-grosse Kopfschmeld-Tablette für den Elefanten. Ich habe noch Brackets von meiner Zahnspange. Ich habe noch die Gold-Brackets, die habe ich jetzt wiedergefunden. Die können wir einschmelzen für die Zahnspange für den Hai. Ja. Die baue ich. Aber du kaufst sie mir ab und dann... Ach so. Ja, wir melden uns. Mein Team meldet sich bei dir. Ich habe tatsächlich jetzt, und das ist wirklich ein grosser Schritt für mich, klingt jetzt albern, aber ich habe tatsächlich diese Woche angefangen, meinen Kleingeldeimer einzuzahlen. Nein! Ich bin jetzt umgezogen, Köln ist raus. Der Moment muss viel grösser. Wir brauchen nur Speech. Dinge können sich verändern. Es muss nicht bleiben, wie es ist. Es muss nicht so schrecklich sein, wie es ist. Dinge müssen sich nicht anstauen. Sei es Armut oder Ungleichheit. Nein, man kann auch sein, figurativ gesprochen, sein Kleingeld einmal nehmen und zur Bank bringen. Dinge können sich verändern.
Manchmal steht die Realität den Träumen im Weg. Und man hat einen Traum, aber man kann ihn nicht umsetzen, weil man ihn nie so umsetzen kann, wie man es sich vorstellt, wie man sich wünscht. Es muss alles perfekt sein. Doch was ich gemerkt habe, ist, dass der Wunsch nach Perfektion, der Traumerfüllung im Weg steht.
Und ich, wenn ich auf den perfekten Moment warte. Doch was ich gemerkt habe, ist, dass der Wunsch nach Perfektion, der Traumerfüllung im Weg steht.
Und ich, wenn ich auf den perfekten Moment warte, den Traum niemals erfülle. Der perfekte Moment ist ein Tag nach meinem Tod. Und deswegen habe ich mich dazu entschieden, nicht so wie ich es wollte, alles auf einmal abzugeben, Und dieses Goldgeklingel einmal erklingen zu lassen, kosmischen Ausmasses und meinen gesamten Eimer einzufüllen in diesen Automaten, der alles schluckt und sich nicht beschwert. Nein, ich musste einsehen, dass es zu gross war und ich musste einsehen, dass auch ein Stück weiter Erfolg zum Sieg führen kann.
Und also habe ich heute eine zur Hälfte gefüllte Mr. Max Plastikflasche und damit einen Teil des Eimers abgegeben und eingefüllt. Wohin? Da gab es bei mir beim Rewe so einen Automaten, wo du es einzahlen kannst. What? Das Ding ist, das Ding ist, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp. Daran bist du doch dreimal vorbeigelaufen schon. Mein Traum war, ich habe einen riesigen Geld, einmal voller Kleingeld, und ich wollte ihn auf einmal abgeben. Ich wollte einen perfekten Zettel haben, auf dem steht 420-Cent-Stücke, 810-Cent-Stücke. Ich wollte diese dicken, fetten Zahlen saftig vor mir haben. So funktioniert die Realität nicht. Aber ich dachte mir, wie soll ich den bewegen? 30 Kilo oder sowas. Hört ihr mir gegegeben für meine Ausstellung? Sag es doch! So, und jetzt habe ich gesagt, nein, ich muss Stück für Stück, dieser Traum ist geplatzt, und jetzt habe ich mir mehrere Mr. Max-Flaschen befüllt. Ja, ich gehört, was du gerade gesagt hast, als ich gesummt habe. Ikea-Tasche. Habe ich alles gehört. Ich muss mich nochmal alles wiederholen. Ikea-Tasche und das habe ich heute das erste abgegeben. Jetzt werde ich die nächsten Tage immer, wenn ich einkaufen gehe, werde ich Kleingeld abgeben und es ist toll, weil es ist lame und nervig, weil du stehst an der Kasse, du kaufst einen für sagen wir mal 30 Euro, aber du legst dann diesen Gutsch, du hast dann wie so einen Pfandbon, aber halt nicht für 1,80 Euro, sondern halt für 300 Euro. Du willst eine Summe auf deinem Konto, wo ich irgendwie plus 800 Euro. Ja, ich lege es doch, aber aber kannst du dir wenigstens merken, weil wie ich dich kenne, du hältst nicht mal mehr ein Buch. Am Ende weißt du gar nicht, wie viel da drin war. Nein, jeder Zettel wird penibel fotografiert und in eine Excel-Tabelle eingetragen, wo ich am Ende dann genau beziffern kann, weil und das möchte ich. Und ihr merkt, wenn ihr auf den Inflationschart guckt, seht ihr, wie langsam sich alles Deflation. Genau, wie die Wirtschaft auch wieder ins richtige Rad kommt, ins Rollen kommt und am Ende Hättest du aber bei VW so abstellen können. Ja, und alle sagen, zum Glück haben wir Trump gewählt, dass jetzt wieder alles funktioniert, aber eigentlich war das meine Münze. Und du hast einfach die Rechte supported, Faschismus-Supported mit deinem Eimer. Und ich möchte nämlich eine Frage stellen an dich und auch an das Publikum. Okay, klingt so, als ob du mich jetzt reingeschoben hast. Welche Münzart liefert am Ende den höchsten Wert? 20 Cent. Du sagst, 20 Cent-Stücke liefern am Ende den höchsten Wert. Also ich meine den Wert in Euro, also Anzahl mal Münzwert. Was denn sonst in Yen oder was? Nee, aber nicht, dass Leute sagen, hier hat es zwei Euro ein Stück. Sondern, nein, sondern, ne, also wenn du am Ende sagst, welche Münzart hat am meisten Geld gebracht, bitte. Genau, weißt du warum? Weil zwei, eins und fünfzig Cent benutzt man häufiger. Das, was du am Ende reingeschmissen hast in den Eimer, wird vor allen Dingen Münzen sein, wo du sagst, man kann das nicht gebrauchen. Und fünfzig Cent ist für dich noch, ah, das kann man gebrauchen, werfe ich nicht in den Eimer. Zwei Euro zum Beispiel habe ich immer sehr selten, weil das kann ich immer noch gut gebrauchen, wenn man Lieferando-Fahrer oder eine Fahrerin kommt. Zwei Euro Trinkgeld. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Deswegen ist es zwei Euro oft weg, hat man eher weniger. Oder man nimmt es nicht nochmal mit, weil diese Riesenmünze, die kann man mal gut gebrauchen. Ein Euro ähnlich. Fünfzig Cent, glaube ich, muss man auch noch. Fünfzig Cent, vielleicht auch mal neue Nummer eins. Aber zwanzig Cent, das sind die ersten Münzen, die drin lassen. Und ne, Kleinvieh macht auch Mist. Ja, ja. Das heißt, schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare, denn die Person, die richtig liegt, kriegt den gesamten Wert aller Münzen. Was? Die Person, die richtig liegt, kriegt von mir den Gesamtwert des Eimers. Ich werde diese Folge nicht hochladen und als einziger kommentieren.
Nee, das ist natürlich jetzt logistisch ein bisschen
schwierig.
Vielleicht muss ich mir das noch überlegen.
Die Person, die dem Gesamtwert am nähersten kommt,
kriegt den ganzen Eimer.
Der Münzart am nähersten kommt.
Nein, dem Gesamtwert des Eimers.
Ach so.
Aber ich will es ja
selber haben.
Ich habe tatsächlich überlegt, ob ich den Eimer auf Instagram
poste und sagt, wer auf den Cent genau richtig
liegt, kriegt alles und dachte mir dann,
ja, aber ich muss das ja nicht ehrlich machen.
Ja.
Damit ich es behalten kann. Und dann dachte ich mir,
vielleicht bin ich einfach nicht der Mensch,
der solche Aktionen machen sollte. Ja, übrigens habe ich das Traumhaus nicht gewonnen. Ich habe das Traumhaus nicht gewonnen. Es ging alles bergab, es hat irgendein anderer genommen. Es gibt ein neues Traumhaus an der Förde. Weiß ich nicht. Hat es tatsächlich, also, ne? Ja, das wäre meine Frage. Es ist ja immer so, aber hat es, wirklich, wenn ihr der Gewinner seid, wenn ihr gerade zuhört, wenn ein Podcast-Ufo-Hörer das Haus gewonnen hat, dann mailt euch bitte. Ihr müsst nicht sagen, wie er heisst, wo das Haus ist, aber einfach nur, jetzt gar nicht aus Helm, einfach nur Stefan Tietze reinzureiben, dass, weil er es im Podcast genannt hat, nicht gewonnen hat und die Wahrscheinlichkeit gesunken ist zu gewinnen.
Und ich werde keine rechtlichen Schritte einleiten.
Denn der Rechtsweg war ja von Anfang an ausgeschlossen.
Es gab nie einen Rechtsweg.
Nein.
Von daher habt ihr überhaupt nichts zu beschlechen.
Das wollen die euch da oben einrichtet, dass es einen Rechtsweg gibt. Es gibt keinen Rechtsweg.
Man muss ihn nicht ausschliessen, weil es gibt ihn nicht.
Trump hat gesagt, der Rechtsweg ist ausgeschlossen.
Der Rechtsweg ist ausgeschlossen. Udo Lindberg. Naja, wir sind in Hamburg. Also natürlich, rutsch ich da mal ab. Es ist um Udo. Aber das tut mir leid. Das heißt, du musst weiterhin in deiner Kaschemme, in deiner Butze, musst du weiterhin wohnen. Ja, kleine Bilder malen. Ja, du kannst leider nicht die großen Bilder malen. Vielleicht würde man in vielen Jahrhunderten, hunderten Jahren sagen, das war noch die Phase, als Stefan Titzel seine guten kleinen Bilder gemalt hat. Als er dann den Erfolg hat und dann die grossen Bilder gemalt hat, wurden sie alle schlecht, irgendwie uninspiriert, zu bombastisch, zu gross gedacht, als es noch intim authentisch war. Da war er gut. Vielleicht ist das wirklich die entscheidende Phase. Kann sein. Ich nehme euch mit auf diese Phase, ich freue mich sehr, von dir zu hören, wie es da geht. Du musst mal was posten, du musst was zeigen. Ich will dich jetzt gar nicht unter Druck setzen, aber du musst bitte unbedingt mal was posten. Bitte, bitte, die Leute würden sich so freuen. Du könntest so viele Leute inspirieren, weil sie sich denken, ich bin besser als Stefan. Ich bin gerade erst mal noch in der Studienphase, Materialstudie, Untergrundstudie, was mache ich hier eigentlich genau, Angstverlierenphase. Ist denn Weiss die beste Farbe für eine Leinwand? Es gibt auch so Leinen, so grau-beige. Aber nicht blau, du kannst nicht mit Blau schon mal anfangen. Nee, aber die meisten grundieren die Bilder ja erst mal in so einem braunen, roten Kram.
Da waren ja viele so Untermalereien gefunden.
Ah.
Mit Röntgen.
Röntgen.
Wurden geröntgen. Röntgen.
Wenn man mal so ein bisschen röntgen, so ein paar Zentimeter.
Das ist ein kleines, das ist jetzt keine klassische Röntgenaufnahme, das ist ein kleines Röntgen.
Röntgen.
Röntgen. Röntgen. Da müssen sie keine Bleischürze anziehen, das ist ja nur ein bisschen Röntgen. Röntgen. Röntgen. Röntgen. Röntgen. Liebe Freunde, ich hoffe, dass es euch gut geht, wenn ihr in den nächsten Tagen schwere Dinge vorhabt. Ihr schafft das. Schwer hebt. Ihr kriegt das hin. Hebt aus den Beinen. He hebt aus den Beinen, hebt aus den Knien, hebt aus den
Fußgelenken, das gesamte Bein.
Was ist das eigentlich mit deiner Oben?
Wer oben?
Du schaust immer nach oben.
Die sagen euch, hebt aus dem Rücken.
Niemand sagt das.
Niemand sagt, hebt aus dem Rücken.
Das wollen die euch alle eintrichtern.
Dieser Trichter existiert nicht.
Und deine Körpersaftphobie, die endet in diesem Trichter, dass dir da wirklich Spucke verschiedene Blutgüsse da wirklich Eiter in den Eimer so reintrichtern.
Leute, habt eine schöne Zeit, tschüsschen, wir sind nach Hause, wir freuen uns nächste Woche, tschau, wies!